nous prenons la route plutôt l'autoroute
la région centre avec son réseau
autoroutier danse est une région très
traverser les paysages défilent cap au
sud pour la champagne berrichonne un des
quatre paysages qui composent la
s'étendent entre bourges qui soudain à
châteauroux ce vaste plateau céréaliers
semble avoir toujours été ainsi et
pourtant sur les hauteurs de vatan notre
rendez vous est arrivé
alexandre est architecte il étudie les
paysages de l'indre depuis 21 ans
pour le conseil d'architecturé
d'urbanisme et de l'environnement
ici il ya cinquante ans on avait un
paysage déjà très ouvert mais qui
étaient destinés essentiellement à
l'élevage est l'élevage des moutons de
façon très excitant expansive parce que
la terre était pauvre et lorsqu'on a
découvert les engrais chimiques ainsi
que la mécanisation ce territoire a subi
une mutation très brutale qui lui a
permis de produire des céréales en
grande quantité un paysage crois que
chacun s'en fait sa propriété sont
propres sa propre définition ça peut
être un motif
ça peut être un motif esthétique mais
derrière un paysage ya surtout des
usages
c'est un paysage qu'on apprécie bien
quand on est dans une logique de
mouvement par contre de façon statique
c'est un paysage qu'on subit et qui peut
être un petit peu agressif on a toujours
été dans un paysage très ouvert les
constructions sont regroupés en îlots on
peut vraiment parler d' îlots au milieu
du paysage un petit peu comme le milieu
d'un océan et les maisons s'agglomèrent
se tasse et d'ailleurs dans les villages
de champagne berrichonne et il est tout
à fait intéressant de remarquer que les
espaces publics sont beaucoup plus dense
et beaucoup plus intime que dans
d'autres régions naturelles du
département web aux gens c'est eux
oui c'est donc je hakim habite la
champagne berrichonne depuis 57 ans il a
vu le paysage change et avec après la
seconde guerre mondiale la disparition d
élevage d'ovins au profit d'une mono
culture céréalière intensive en
contraste avec les longues plein travail
et les villages au creux de petite
vallée riche en eau reste des oasis de
verdure où vivent petit exploitant et
ouvriers agricoles
ça crée un bouchon vers j'étais gosse à
la rivière là la rivière allier poretti
ligne à la phase aller à faisait db en
dhr avec des aubiers pire il y avait
plein de charme ce village là il y avait
sept personnes qui habitaient là dedans
c'est plus personne aujourd'hui on est
plus de 2 dès les années 60 et jusqu'à
la fin du xxème siècle la mécanisation
entraîne un moindre besoin de main
d'oeuvre des villages et hameaux se
désertifie au profit des vignes
tania on arrive à l'extrémité de la
champagne berrichonne ici à levroux
hornet à l'extrémité ouest
on voit que le grand paysage devient
beaucoup plus vert qu'on abandonne un
petit peu les céréales pour entrer dans
une région de polyculture pour ce qui
concerne l'avenir de la champagne
berrichonne on n'a pas avoir d'états
d'âme
il faudra toujours nourrir les gens et
donc on continuera à produire en grande
quantité
depuis l'époque gallo romaine la
champagne berrichonne a toujours été une
terre de grandes propriétés agricoles
les derniers romans brement renforce
cette vision d'un paysage uniforme sans
fin tout juste interrompue par les
autoroutes et les éoliennes qui
contribuent à créer un paysage rural du
21e siècle